for all the blood pumping brawls
sentimental scenes in general doom and
gloom seen on-screen and Avengers
infinity war there was just as much
laughter banter and goofs that played
out behind the scenes and thanks to the
blu-ray release of infinity war which
features a two minute long gag reel
viewers at home can witness the best of
those bloopers in one handy spot
something wrong with long after Bruce
Banner crash lands at the New York
sanctum following his cosmic faceoff
with Thanos he meets up with Ironman
Wong and dr. strange Wong and Doctor
Strange give a crash course on the
Infinity stones
Bruce explains just how wicked Thanos is
an Iron Man goes to call Captain America
for help hoping a reconcile after the
falling out in Captain America Civil War
but when Ironman notices that the wind
has picked up the four men slowly turned
to face the sanctum Street side door and
realized that Thanos's lieutenants have
already touched down on earth pretty
dramatic stuff right well during filming
actor Benedict Wong could really keep it
that way
[Music]
bumbling Benedict and Mushmouth mark
they may be two of the smartest
characters in the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe but for a few minutes
during filming Avengers infinity war
Doctor Strange and Bruce Banner
definitely acted like a couple of
doofuses when Bruce and dr. strange
emerged from a portal and greet Iron Man
and Pepper Potts in the park
actors Benedict Cumberbatch and Mark
Ruffalo seem to forget how to like talk
and stuff I'm dark just the I'm doctor I
can't walk at the not me yeah
Falcon gets funny Anthony Mackey's
Falcon wasn't as major player in
Avengers infinity war as some of the
other superheroes but a lack of
narrative influence doesn't equate to a
lack of quality bloopers during the
battle in Wakanda Falcon soars through
the sky to take down the black order and
the outriders between takes Mackie made
sure to paint a great mental picture for
everyone of what his scene would look
like when the movie was finished flying
about 80 miles an hour just super big
chocolate missile when shooting another
portion of the Wakanda battle Mackie had
another important acting moment this
time with co-director Joe Russo hey
Russo you want me to go Jamie Foxx on
this look
Oh everybody put on your sunglasses
denzel's coming out and that wasn't the
only time Mackey discussed his acting
process between tapes during the film's
intense final sequence falcon rests
slumped on the wakandan forest floor
it's a heartbreaking moment for viewers
turns out it's because Mackey was
channeling his infinity war co-starred
on war machine Cheadle for inspiration
going for cheetah on this tape cheetah
black panther versus the bleeding goats
boys yet passionate and undeniably
powerful chadwick boseman Stu Chawla
better known as Black Panther is
generally able to keep his cool under
even the worst of situations this rings
especially true in infinity war when
Black Panther gifts Sebastien Stan's war
wethered Bucky Barnes a new bionic arm
and suddenly asked him to join the
resistance against Thanos whose black
order was minutes away from landing in
Wakanda this one may be tired of war
with a white wolf has rested long enough
upon seeing his upgrade Bucky and black
panther have a simple dramatic exchange
where is a fight on its way the blooper
reel features an extended version of
this moment which is less dramatic the
problem a couple of extras just couldn't
keep quiet during filming specifically
two chatty goats I know you have found
something
my sense of peace okay now you are going
to [ __ ] a hairy situation nearing the
third act of the film black widow Bruce
Banner
Captain America Scarlet Witch Falcon war
machine and vision all traveled to
Wakanda to visit Shuri the genius
younger sister of T'Challa who's known
for advanced technological creations
like the latest version of the black
panther suit the group hopes that
showery can safely and successfully
remove the mine stone from visions
forehead and that they can destroy it
before Thanos seizes it and uses it to
power the Infinity Gauntlet snap his
fingers and kill half the universe once
in the lush futuristic country the
heroes wind up preparing to battle the
purple muscled despot with Black Widow
joining the fight inside a ship
alongside wakandan warriors and members
of the Dora milosh a like so many scenes
throughout the film this sequence was
shot in front of a green screen but also
required the use of a machine to
simulate real wind whipping past and the
Machine kind of worked a little too well
both in this scene and in one starring
Elizabeth Olsen as the Scarlet Witch
from earlier in the film because you're
worthless
should they ever get tired of acting
Johansson Olsen and the rest of the
infinity war cast could totally do
shampoo commercials instead
[Music]